i've titled this re-introduction to
trigonometry because it is the start of
the topic but
we've met trigonometry before right um
tell me some things you know about
trigonometry just throw out some words
or some ideas what can you tell me
because you've been doing this for a
couple years now yeah fantastic
triangles i'm so glad you went there
first because
it's in the name right in fact try gone
try gone
uh that's that just means triangle right
except that gone is just the greek word
for angle
so we're interested in three angled
shapes
what does metri mean like when you see
like geometry or telemetry or what's
what's that generally referring to
i give a clue i'm really obsessed with
words as you might be able to tell just
by
what i've done the last two minutes we
actually have a word that we usually
associate with this
like say when you talk about centimeters
meters kilometers etc
this is the metric system right so what
does that mean
metric versus metric what's the idea
yeah go ahead imagine
it's our measurement yeah so this really
this whole topic it's just a fancy name
for
a measuring triangles what kinds of
things do we measure
in triangles we've already talked about
one of them
angles thank you great we're interested
in how big angles are but these aren't
the only things what are the other
things we're interested in
yeah sides sides angles that's kind of
it right
so i'm also going to put it and these
are you know by virtue of being three
angled they're also three
sided okay now um you put your pens out
of your hand because what i want to do
with you first before we start to dig
back into the content of this is
i want to do a little activity i just
got very lucky that this happens to be
the lesson for mrs bray that i get to
cover for you guys
i want to give you an illustration of
why we should care about this right
because i assume there will be some of
you
who may be like oh yeah i might do
something like this in the future if i'm
an engineer or an architect
but i'm also going to assume that will
not be most of you it might be
none of you actually because they're
just a very small proportion of society
so i want to give you instead something
we all care about
that is why trigonometry is relevant to
us
which you've actually been doing for how
old are you guys now like 16 now 16 yeah
you've been doing for the last 16 years
you just didn't know it okay here's what
i like to do a little experiment
i'll actually put your pens out of your
hands because i'd like you to hold up an
index finger for me
and i like you to hold up in front of
your face so that
you can actually see me behind your
finger so you're all kind of
going to be facing this way okay all
right so i'm going to do the same thing
now what i'd like to do is focus on your
finger focus closely on it
and now what i want you to do is keep
your finger where it is but
i want you to notice that behind your
finger i'm all blurry do you see that
like i'm all out of focus yeah if you if
any of you are interested in photography
it's a depth of field issue right so i'm
blurry your finger is sharp
okay keep your finger where it is i'd
like you now
with your finger there now can you focus
on me so here i am
your finger's still there in view but do
you notice something weird has happened
to your finger
don't focus on it because it'll ruin the
effect do you notice if you're looking
at me and i'm sharp here
you're now seeing two copies of your
finger did you notice that
yeah and they're both blurry that's a
bit weird right i don't know if you ever
noticed that okay
focus back on your finger like oh it's
okay it's back to being one
it's just something weird my eyes are
doing okay and we want to tease out what
you're doing now right
come back to me keep your finger there i
can fix that double vision problem that
you've got right you've got two copies
of your finger there
i want you to close one of your eyes
you're still focused on me yeah your
finger's blurry but you can see me
sharply behind her
so now you've just got one blurry finger
which is a relief because you are indeed
only holding one finger
but now just um while you're still
focusing on me so your finger's still
blurry i want you to swap eyes
and then swap back do you notice your
finger doing something weird
as you swap back and forth keep going
back and forth between your eyes
okay you can stop now because it's
hilarious you're looking very amusing
okay what was your finger doing how
would you describe it
it was like going it's like here and
then it just you switched eyes
and suddenly it was in another spot
right now what you're experiencing now
is what we call stereoscopic vision
right you got two eyes i had to check as
everyone walked in because sometimes
i don't know if any of you guys have
heard a guy named adam spencer adam
spencer he's like this maths geek um
he's only got one eye well his other
eyes glass so he doesn't stay with it
right
um so you got two eyes stereoscopic or
sometimes you call it binocular
by nocula vision right i want you to
think about this right why was it you
can reason this through with me
why was it that as you switched eyes
back and forth
your finger was appearing to move around
why was that happening
everything better i'm sure you guys can
work it out i've done this with little
kids and
they work it out what's your theory
because you're looking at it from
different
angles and like you see more you've got
like
on this side you have more space here
it's more close to this side yeah yeah
very good
if you if you were holding up your
finger like i was i was holding my
finger up sort of um
so my fingernail was facing to one side
um as you switch eyes right
if you're using say in my case my left
eye my left eye can't see my fingernail
at all because it's on the wrong side
right and then from the other side all i
can see is figuring out because that's
the perspective
issue right now here's the cool thing
right
every second of every day as you look
out the world around you
right um you're seeing two copies of the
world
all the time you're just your brain is
just really clever
at sticking them together and working
out i can try and make them cohere but
when you put something very close to
your face
your two eyes see something that is very
different to each other
right because the difference between
them i mean what is it like
10 centimeters something like that that
distance is exacerbated when you've got
things close up to you right
now underneath where you've drawn your
heading right i just should make a very
very small diagram for me okay
i want you to put in for me uh two
eyes looking up at the world
okay now this is actually genius
i'm particularly conscious of this
because
my wife and my daughter both have this
condition where they can't do what i'm
about to describe and so i'm very
conscious of it and we don't really
think about it because it just happens
automatically in the background
if you've got your two eyes right and
they're looking at some object let's
just put like
an x out here in the front right they're
looking at some object
what is the way that our brain can tell
whether something is
large and far away or small
and close up right because you know if
you like blew up a poster of somebody
and put it really far away presumably
look roughly the same
but your brain can tell that it's
actually massive and often the distance
here's how it does right
as your eyes look towards this one
object
right your brain is secretly measuring
this angle in here constantly which it
can do
because it has these two different
points right so if for example you went
around the world and you just have one
eye open
okay have you done this experiment
before like you try to catch a ball when
you've only got one eye open it's almost
impossible
because this depth perception thing
can't happen it can't work out right
so your brain is doing what we call
triangulation
why do you think it's called
triangulation
you're forming a triangle right one
point your two eyes and you've got this
triangle you've got this angle
and therefore your body rather your
brain works out it infers these two
distances it does a calculation in the
background without you thinking about it
okay in other words why does
trigonometry matter why do we care about
it right it's the relationship between
sides and angles
that yeah like it also lets us measure
the world and build stuff but actually
it's just something that your brain has
evolved
to do to understand the world around you
okay
there are three and i'll give you a clue
there are three
particular ideas or concepts within
trigonometry that you spent all your
time
in years 9 and 10 working on can you
help me remember what they are
all together yeah say louder sign
cause and tan very good do you guys know
what their abbreviations of because all
three are abbreviations
what's ah okay so you've actually
answered another thing for me which is
fine i'll jot that down
so this is an acronym that helps me know
what they mean but does anyone know what
the words mean
the actual words
yeah very good so sine sine is short for
sine and you should drop this down by
the way you can pick your pen back up
cos is short for cosine
so clearly there's some kind of
connection between these two
and then tan does stand for
tangent which seems like a weird one off
on the side
not a rhetorical question but if the
answer is no that will tell me where i'm
going to go in this double does anyone
know
why tangent is called tangent it's the
weird like one on the side has anyone
been taught it before
if not that's okay i will teach you
later on but i just want to see i don't
tell you something you don't really know
all right that's right uh let's then
unpacked you you told me this
acronym here that relates to sine cosine
tangent uh let's do this first bit the s
o h what does that stand for
opposite over hypotenuse so if we had
some say
angle theta right we would say that sine
theta
is equal to the opposite on the
hypotenuse
right we've sort of used this to help us
remember what about
the cah in the middle what's that gonna
mean
cos theta equals what adjacent on
hypotenuse is fantastic
and then lastly we've got uh tan
bringing up the rear so if i if i have
tan theta we've got again
each time we're getting this ratio
between two sides and it's going to be
opposite over adjacent fantastic so
underneath this acronym
it kind of implies a diagram doesn't it
a triangle that's what's trigonometry
and we should draw this all together
a triangle which is
uh i've got some angle theta like say
here
and importantly this is not just any
triangle right
these particular we call them the
trigonometric ratios
we've only been used to working with
them in particular kinds of triangles
i've tried
badly i didn't use a ruler but what kind
of triangles are we interested in mostly
right angled very good so let's go ahead
and chuck a right angle here
so a whole idea of opposite hypotenuse
adjacent
is its positional language it tells you
where the sides are it labels the sides
relative to their position when you
think about theta okay
so if we were to name these let's call
this say a
i'll make this one b and then c okay
can you name for me the side that's
opposite
bc fantastic so we'll put opposite over
here
which side is the adjacent side ac
wonderful
and then of course we have left the side
opposite the right angle the longest
side in every right angle triangle
you've got the hypotenuse over here